good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
here on the breakfast show on sky news
this wednesday morning the cost of
living set to ramp up today for millions
of workers as the national insurance
hike
kicks in as part of a plan to raise cash
for the nhs and social care
is it worth it we'll ask the health
secretary sanji javid very shortly plus
as the west prepares to hit russia with
even more sanctions a bold claim from
russia will ask the former head of the
armed forces general lord danette about
that the leader of the lib dems sir ed
davey is with us as is labour's peter
carl also on the programme pretty packed
isn't it it's wednesday the 6th of april
new sanctions to target russia as sky
news questions russia's top men at the
un about pictures of civilian bodies in
butcher
don't forget that the
video that president zelinski displayed
today is a fake read my twitter
i'm in ukraine where president zielenski
says the measures imposed by the west
must match the crimes committed by
russia
pay packet pressure higher national
insurance contributions to begin for
millions of workers from today to raise
cash for the nhs and social care
i'm at a petrol station in essex as
prices at the pump surge by their
fastest rate on record despite a cut in
fuel duty
divorce on demand the biggest shake-up
in divorce law in half a century ends
the blame game and makes it easier to
cut ties
[Music]
can you tell the difference did sammy
switches oh why help to shape ed
sheeran's number one hit that's the
accusation before a court a judge will
deliver its decision just before 10 this
morning we'll bring that to you live
also coming up on the programme for you
wherever you're watching us around the
world today the departure of manchester
airports md follows chaotic scenes there
will get tips on how to plan your easter
holiday from a trio of industry experts
and also the theatre that opened its
doors as a food bank over the pandemic
will speak to the artistic director of
the slung low in leeds about the
difficulties people are facing now amid
spiraling bills
[Music]
very good morning everybody could russia
be facing more sanctions
and will it make any difference to their
maneuvers in ukraine let's bring you the
latest developments so far this morning
got more details for you in just a few
moments time fresh uk intelligence says
russian troops may have prevented aid
reaching the 160 000 people still
trapped in mariopol in an attempt to
force a defeat eu leaders meet today in
strasbourg to discuss proposed new
sanctions including a ban on russian
coal imports
meanwhile the kiev region police chief
sahar told sky news 1200 war crimes have
been registered in the area
sky news has seen more evidence of
civilian bodies in butcher russia's
ambassador to the un told ius
correspondent mark stone the video is a
fake here's his report
it was the weekend images emerging from
butcher which prompted this meeting of
the security council they'd invited
vladimir zelensky to join them but were
not prepared for what he would show them
what they saw in the chamber cannot be
broadcast here but the images of dead
bodies are horrific
they're from several towns across
ukraine some of them charred hands tied
behind backs women and children among
them we cannot yet independently verify
the context behind them but the pattern
is clear killings mass executions rapes
zilenski called for russia with its
power to veto anything this place tries
to do be removed from the council
remove russia as an aggressor
and a source of war
so it cannot block decisions about its
own aggression its own war
but there is no mechanism for russia's
removal and so its top diplomat is free
to claim that all these allegations are
nonsense you say it's all fabrication
what's happening in butcher
it's all a fabrication i said i said
i said that this this photographs
appeared
uh only on the third of april while we
left the place on the 30th of march but
the the satellite evidence shows those
bodies were there when you were in
charge of that town
it's not true
nothing today can be taken for granted
okay and don't forget that the
video that president zilensky displayed
today is a fake read by twitter
why is it fake
because it is a fake it was the people
are not dead
the people are dead but they were shot
elsewhere where there were no russian
troops it was it appeared before read
the internet to read the users
the uk holds the current presidency of
the security council and had called the
urgent meeting
i suspect that the security council has
never seen a video
with such horrifying images on it i
don't think there's any reason to doubt
those images the important thing now is
that there is accountability for what is
clearly war crimes
from this top body down russia is truly
isolated now and yet the killing goes on
the focus ahead is to build a case
against it to counter the denials with
facts and evidence mark stone sky news
in new york
dominic standing by in levitt for us
again this morning in western ukraine
hello to dominic hearing from russia
they're just not buying it they're
saying all of this is completely fake
i mean yeah they are they're lying
through their teeth okay aren't they as
they as they did over the skripal affair
as they did in chechnya as they did in
syria and we're hearing a number of
versions of events by different russian
diplomats and that's their playbook
that's their murders operandi it's to
tell lots of different lies
uh to cast enough doubt not to
necessarily put forward a compelling
version of the truth but to obscure the
truth nebanzia they're sounding
confident they're really confident that
just read his twitter go on the internet
you'll see that these videos are fakes
whereas the satellite imagery we're
seeing uh the harrowing eyewitness
testimony from our reporters and many
others and what the ukrainians are
saying and what international
investigators are finding in butcher and
other places is evidence of a massacre
committed by the russians not just there
but evidence of similar things going on
in other parts of ukraine they're also
using weapons that shouldn't be used in
war like cluster bombs the msf saying
that they saw cluster bombs being used
against a hospital in mikaela so a whole
catalogue of atrocities being committed
by the russians and the ukrainians are
hugely impatient and frustrated with the
response in the west they say the
sanctions that are being considered now
are simply not enough because
the eu is handing over 775 million euros
a day
for oil and gas they are considering or
they're going to stop coal imports but
coal imports are come to four billion
euros a year so that's effectively four
days worth of oil and gas payments to
the russians and what the ukrainians are
saying is that money is going to be used
directly to fund the next phase in this
war that money that europeans are paying
for oil and gas for their manufacturing
industry and to have their homes heated
is going to go into russia's military
that will pay for replacing the hundreds
of tanks and armored personnel carriers
and heavy armor they've lost there for
the next phase in the war which
ukrainians say is completely
unacceptable hey dominic thank you lots
to put to the health secretary this
morning sadie javid who is joining us
now hello to your health secretary
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning let's start with good
morning ukraine if we may you're a
father of four as i know when you see
images like those on the front page of
say the daily mirror this morning where
a little girl
has got her contact details uh written
on her back in case her parents are
murdered by putin and his henchmen how
much does that strengthen your resolve
to have him removed from office
i think it it strengthens the result for
all of us and what we're seeing
unfolding now in ukraine is
absolutely appalling these atrocities
we're now sadly seeing almost daily on
our tv screens and and the image you
just talked of you know when i first saw
that image i think yesterday you know it
could have been my daughter it could be
anyone's daughter their son and just to
think that's what parents are having to
do
in ukraine right now because of the
choice that vladimir putin has made and
we should never forget this is a choice
this was not a a a war for any other
reason
than something that vladimir putin had
just chosen to do and and we will uh
continue to help ukraine in every way
that we can whether that's military
support whether it's with support for
sanctions on russia and humanitarian
support and does that include regime
change
look
it's ultimately up to the the russian
people about
the leadership of their country but i do
think
the prime minister our prime minister
was right yesterday to appeal directly
uh to the russian people in the way that
he did yeah i know a lot of russians i'm
sure many of people listening do and
they are
the vast majority they're just ordinary
decent compassionate people and do they
really want to see this war unfolding
especially in the way that it is
in in their name and if there's an
opportunity for them to to
to to you make their feelings heard to
their own government and i hope that
they listen to to boris johnson and
others uh and and react
okay you're in a hospital today of
course because you want to talk to us
about the hike in national insurance
how on earth can it be a fair tax it
does seem to unfairly tax those who can
at least afford uh to fund this this is
going to be used for health and social
care levy of course isn't it but but
aren't there better ways of doing that
well let me just first say what this new
levee does it kicks in today the new
health and social care levy it's all of
the funding raised from it is going to
go towards the extra 39 billion pounds
we're going to put in over the next
three years into health and social care
it's going to pay in the nhs uh for
activity levels that are some hundred
and thirty percent of pre-pandemic it's
gonna be nine million more scans tests
and and procedures meaning people will
get seen a lot earlier why is any of
this necessary whether it's for health
or social care it's because of the
impact
of the pandemic we know it's
unprecedented it's been the biggest
challenge in our lifetime and the impact
of that is going to continue for many
years you asked me about the fairness of
it is you know when we spend money on
public services whether it's nhs or
anything else for that matter the money
can only come from two sources it's
either it's you raise it
directly from people today that's
through taxes or
you borrow it which is essentially
you're asking the next generation to pay
for it i think it is right that we pay
for what we are going to use as a
country but we do it in a in a fair way
and this levy
the way it's being raised is the the top
15 percent of earners will pay almost 50
percent and i think it's the right way
to do this if you were chancellor and
you're still chancellor and you saw half
a million kids falling into absolute
poverty because of your measures
would you think twice
i think look i am not chancellor i'm the
health secretary my job is to is to make
sure that we're doing everything we can
to recover from the pandemic when it
comes to health and and social care but
when it comes to the treasury and the
chancellor and the support that's been
provided i think that the focus is
absolutely right when it comes to the
cost of living i don't think anyone out
there listing thinks that the government
can mitigate a worldwide inflation
crisis for in every way for every single
person but what government can do is
support those that need it most and the
actions that we've taken on energy bills
for example with 9 billion pounds of
support uh on on the new hardship fund
for local authorities for those that are
most vulnerable and also most important
of all of supporting work you know the
best way out of poverty for anyone is in
work we've now in this country we've got
one of the lowest unemployment rates
that this country has ever seen the
lowest youth unemployment rate we've had
for decades and that doesn't happen by
accident it's happening because of the
policies of this government and we're
supporting those people in work with
more tax cuts okay
as health secretary then as you as you
pointed out to me is it acceptable to
administer
an electric shock
to someone who feels that they are in
the wrong body
no i don't think so no no of course not
so why has that been removed from the
build for the queen's speech so
transgender people would still
undergo that sort of con conversion
therapy which sounds inhumane to me
well when it comes to conversion therapy
it is absolutely right as the government
has said that we we ban you the
so-called conversion therapy
for lgb people when it comes to trends i
do think that we need to be more careful
yeah you asked me again as health
secretary uh in my mind is for example
is the recent report by dr hillary cash
she's one of the
most experienced pediatricians in this
country she just published an interim
report just a few weeks ago and she
talked about
how
children and young people
when they when they
say they have gender dysphoria it is
right for medical experts to to be able
to question that and to determine that
what the cause might be is it a genuine
case of uh gender identity dysphoria or
could it be that that individual is
suffering from some child sex abuse for
example or could it be linked to
bullying so i think it is it is right to
take the approach that we have which is
to ban uh good conversion therapy for
lgp
lgb but but to take a a a much more sort
of sensitive approach when it comes to
trans yeah but again my question is does
that include allowing people to have an
electric shock because they feel they're
in the wrong body if it sounds inhumane
to me no it doesn't no it no it doesn't
and there are also already you know
there are many laws in place uh that
that you should prevent anything of that
type of anything part of the therapy
isn't it it can be anything dangerous
could it be should that be against the
law
well it it i don't think that anyone
should be administered electric shock
for for the reasons that you're saying
and uh there are laws in place that
would protect i think i think that would
count as abuse and it would already be
against the law
okay um thanks very much for
clarification on that i'm sure that will
develop further throughout the course of
the day but i do want to ask you if i
may about um
covid and the new uh guidelines that
were being given apparently there's nine
separate symptoms now as far as kovid is
concerned that you should be checking
for before you go to work one of them
includes there they go one of them
includes uh tiredness um or a headache
um if you've got tiredness or a headache
would you still go to work
no if i had
first of all i think is absolutely right
as we learn more about covid and also as
as we come across new variants
that our experts your update the
symptoms and this there are still three
uh major symptoms
but it's right that others have been
added just to give people you know a bit
more information about what may or may
not be covered now just taking any one
or two of those you've just picked uh
headaches and tiredness does it in
itself
say that you've got covered it you may
have but especially if you've got some
of the more uh the the the where we have
more information so for example if you
have a a sense of uh
loss of your your taste or if you have a
cough that's developed that you didn't
have before or if you have a fever those
are the three main symptoms people
should look out for to answer your
question directly if i had a headache or
uh i was feeling a bit tired
it depends how tired i felt uh i might
want to get some more sleep
and if i had a bit of a headache i'd
first reach for the neurofen
uh
as a secretary of state i'm sure you're
pretty tired almost all of the time very
busy job i'm sure um talk to me about
kierstama
he has said that despite what the prime
minister told us he presided over
widespread criminality in his office
talking about partygate
what should happen as far as party fines
are concerned dominic raab has said that
it was what happened that was against
the law
do you agree that the prime minister
presided over widespread criminality in
his office
what i agree with is i think what we
have all learned over the last few
months is that there were
certainly there are events uh that took
place in in downing street during the
height of the pandemic that needed to
and and are being properly investigated
they should be investigated by the
proper authorities and that's exactly
what's happening uh that the police are
continuing their investigations as i
understand it but this is really a
matter for the police i don't think it's
appropriate for ministers any minister
including myself to to talk about what
the police may or may not do well
they've already issued 20 fines and when
we were talking about kovid you did want
to answer my question directly so if i
could ask this one again please did the
prime princess did the prime minister
forgive me preside over widespread
criminality in his office
well when you ask me about kobe that's a
the matter that relates directly uh to
me and my my job uh and it's not uh
something for an independent authority
when you're asking about uh matters of
um
of the law uh this is rightly in a in a
in a democracy like households
it is a matter for the police no
nonsense
police have already issued 20 fines come
on we know what the police think i'm
asking you whether you agree with the
police that there's been widespread
calling
i know what the police have uh published
i know nothing more or less than that uh
we know about the number of fines i have
no idea uh who has received those fines
uh or not uh but i i i just hesitate to
comment on this further why i do know
who's received
come on minister we know that at least
one person who was in charge of ethics
in downing street at the time received a
fine because she told us that she did we
know that 19 other fines have been
issued as well on 20 separate occasions
more to come the law was broken in
downing street ergo the prime minister
presided over law breaking in downing
street
we will we will learn more about this
short from the police there will also be
a final report uh from sue gray again an
independent report and i think that's
what i'll wait for before i say anything
further okay thanks for joining us i
know you've got a busy day ahead thank
you for taking the time to speak to us
on the program thank
you let's find out what's happening as
far as the papers are concerned this
morning you heard what the health
secretary said just a few moments ago
about the little one who had her contact
details written on her back in case her
parents
were murdered by putin's henchmen the
metro reflecting on what's happening in
ukraine you've been on the vodka that's
the question asked by the metro after
russia's man at the united nations tried
to deny his country has committed war
crimes in ukraine
telegraph quotes ukraine's president in
his address to the u.n that it should
stop putin and if it can't it should
dissolve itself
while the guardian leads with
zielinski's renewed demands for russian
leaders to stand trial over their
actions and the mail has the message
from boris johnson to the people of
russia don't let putin do this in your
name
we'll have an eyewitness account from
the town of bucha where it's alleged
russian troops carried out war crimes
that's coming up shortly and also on the
programme
as western allies prepare for the
sanctions against russia we'll speak to
the former head of the british army
general lord richard dannett
the leader of the liberal democrats ed
davey will be with me in the studio this
morning his party is calling for a slash
in vat to help families struggling to
pay their bills
and with people around the country
having to tighten the first strings as
rises in the cost of living begin to
bite we'll hear from labour's shadow
northern ireland secretary
from today people's take home pain will
be squeezed as an increase in national
insurance takes effect it comes as the
prices at petrol pumps are rising at
their fastest rate ever the average cost
of a liter of petrol rose by 11.6 pence
to end march on
163.3 diesel prices rose even more
sharply up 22.1 pence per liter to 177.3
the increases came despite chancellor
ishisunak implementing a 5 p per litre
cut in fuel duty
on the 23rd of march iva standing by for
us at a forecourt in essex this morning
more and more expensive to fill up what
are mostly saying where you are this
morning iva good morning
yeah morning k those figures you
mentioned are just staggering aren't
they especially when you consider just
how high prices were already at the
beginning of march before these record
rises here in abridge in essex the
prices on the four court are just below
those ones you're quoting but still very
very high
and i was speaking to a man just now
who's filling up his van he's a window
fitter he's travels quite far for work
today driving to swinton and he says he
now spends on average 75 pounds a day on
diesel which equates to around half of
his earnings now and this is despite
that 5p cut in fuel duty from the
chancellor last month that is tantamount
to a drop in the ocean really compared
to these record rises they're being
driven by the war in ukraine which is
causing surging wholesale costs and it
all of course means yet more pain in our
pockets today is the day that national
insurance hike as you say comes into
force millions of us have just had our
energy bills at home rocket by around
700 pounds a year car taxes going up
council tax going up water bills going
up as well for some the cost of living
crisis and rising prices are inescapable
okay thanks a lot thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you uh now the managing
director at manchester airport that's
karen smart she's quit after weeks of
chaos for travellers it comes as the
airport's management met with political
leaders and unions on tuesday to discuss
the current uh
concerning situation as well as pay and
conditions
in a statement manchester airport chief
exec charlie cornish said i am sorry to
lose karen after her years of valuable
service but also understand her desire
to return to the south for family
reasons and indeed to explore
new career opportunities
while there are sure to be further
challenges ahead are you laughing along
with me at home this morning i'm
confident we will soon start to see the
benefits of the recovery plans karen has
helped put in place so it's obviously
nothing to do with the chaos at the
airport at all she's just decided to
step back for family reasons
that's what mps usually say now a group
of sri lankan mps from the governing
party are warning of violence and
anarchy within the country unless an
interim government isn't put in place
protesters have continued to demand the
resignation of the president blaming him
for the country's worst economic crisis
in decades
and republicans in the american state of
oklahoma have passed a law that will
make carrying out an abortion
illegal the measure which is aimed at
doctors carries a penalty of up to 10
years in prison and the only exception
allowed would be if the mother's life
was in danger
now back home it's the biggest shake-up
to divorce law in half a century from
today in england and wales married and
civil partnership couples will be able
to get divorced without having to blame
the other person aisha zaheed reports
for sarah 13 years of marriage came to a
bitter end what should have been a
straightforward divorce was complicated
by legislation the difficulty was the
reasons for the divorce so you were
given five options and only one really
was suitable for us which was the
unreasonable behavior
and it didn't again it didn't really
suit our needs because we just simply
fell out of love and we didn't have many
bad things in our marriage um so you're
almost trying to
exaggerate some of the not so nasty
things that happen between us so i guess
it just kind of created some kind of
animosity between us
in the biggest change to divorce law in
50 years new legislation in england and
wales ends the blame game
scrapping the need for couples to
apportion the blame for the breakdown of
their marriage it means for the first
time couples can apply for divorce
jointly and one partner refusing a
divorce can't stand in the way they're
reforms that experts welcome you hear so
many stories
of people coming out of the divorce
process being utterly
bereft with huge mental health issues
that can lead to debt and it can lead to
the breakdown the further breakdown of
relationships within the family and so
if you have a more amicable way of
approaching divorce
you avoid all of those problems the
government says this new legislation is
part of wider action to reform the
family justice system ultimately it's
hoped it will make an already difficult
time that bit more bearable for many
aisha zahid sky news
ed sheeran yay due to find out the
result of his high court battle over the
copyright of his 2017 hit shape of you
do you remember it of course you don't
love it judge will give a ruling today
over whether his chart-topping single
copied elements of sammy switch's song
oh why
[Music]
switch is a grime artist he alleges the
oi hook in shape of you is strikingly
similar to an oh why refrain in his
track something sheeran and his team
completely deny we'll give you the
latest result as soon as it comes in
expecting that around about 9 30 9 45 as
soon as it comes in we'll bring that to
you live of course meantime let's find
out whether the sun's going to be
shining on ed and the rest of us today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
turning colder over the next few days
with blustery showers turning
increasingly wintry on thursday mostly
mild windy and showery start but the
chilly north of scotland has more
general rain sleet and hill snow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
let's tell you about the home secretary
should we pretty patel she says police
have made the biggest cocaine bust since
2015 nearly four tons of the drug hidden
in boxes
of bananas never in my bananas were
seized by the uk border force at
southampton docks last month the bust
was worth an estimated can you guess
300 million
pounds that's a lot of bananas isn't it
engelbert humperdinck
he has been made an mve during an
investiture service at windsor castle
and we've had him on the program before
very very charming man he 85 now can you
believe it he joined a host of other
people receiving the royal honours from
the princess royal
engelbert whose real name is
not angle but humperduke but arnold
dorsey rose to prominence in the late
60s with chart-topping hits including
release me and save the last waltz
remember that others collecting awards
included the rocker rick wakeman the
actor sir jonathan price and the former
rugby player rob
burrow we wish him well don't we
first programme this morning so far
western allies prepare new sanctions
against russian coal and finance amid
growing evidence of war crimes committed
by its troops in ukraine
from today millions of britons will have
to pay more in national insurance which
the government says will be used to fund
the nhs and social care sector
it'll now be easier to end a marriage
without assigning blame in the biggest
shift of divorce law in england and
wales in 50 years
[Music]
i want to talk to you in more detail
about what's happening in ukraine joined
by the former head of the british army
general lord richard daniel hello to my
lord to you my lord thank you for
joining us on the programme um
dos ukraine have to start to consider
seeding
some
land in to the russians in order to
achieve peace
well i think um
we
president olensky is doing a fantastic
job he's leading his country
extraordinary well and they're fighting
with huge determination i think we can
all recognize that um i think they are
now realizing that they're going to have
to
increase their
their operations in the east of the
country that's clearly where the
russians are now going to concentrate
their efforts
and
it's very good to hear that nato
yesterday
ministers met and agreed to up the
sanctions and many countries bilaterally
are supporting ukraine with more weapons
um their fight is our fight and it's
extremely good that the west is staying
united and supporting ukraine in the way
that it is
always has to be give and take though
doesn't though in order to try to
achieve
peace
do you have a view on on the next region
um
okay unusually i couldn't quite hear
your question could you be kind enough
to say it again yes i said we always
there always has to be give and take
when it comes to try to achieving peace
and i wondered if you did have a view on
the donetsk region of ukraine and what
should happen to it
well this is a difficult one um
it is a fact that many who live in the
donbass region those two provinces uh
are russian speakers of course they are
and many of them are focused and
oriented towards russia but the fact
remains that that territory is ukrainian
now this is the great dilemma that
president zielenski is going to have to
wrestle with
is he going to insist that every square
kilometer of ukrainian soil remains
ukrainian soil
or is he going to have to accept reality
on the ground that
luhansk and donetsk provinces might
become occupied by the russians and
might have to be seated to russia and
indeed there is this very difficult
issue of the land corridor that the
russians have almost completed achieving
between crimea through mario paul uh
into the donbass region
and this i think is the great dilemma
for ukraine it's the great dilemma for
the west do
they compromise and allow those eastern
provinces and that corridor to go to
russia or do they hold out do we hold
out continuing to support ukraine maybe
the west having to up its support uh in
a military sense to ukraine and
insisting that every square kilometer of
ukrainian territory remains ukrainian
that is a huge dilemma and i don't think
that um people have got the answer to
that one yet
and as far as odessa is concerned we
know of course that it's a a port city
incredibly important
to ukraine and we were speaking
to um
yesterday just tobias elwood and he was
saying that we need to um patrol that
the u.n needs to patrol that region on
behalf of ukraine do you agree
well odessa is extraordinarily important
odessa must remain in ukrainian hands
it'll be their only major port to get
their exports particularly their wheat
grain exports out into the international
sea lanes so that is extraordinarily
important but you raise an interesting
point whether there should be a third
force an intervention at some point in
ukraine um it would be unacceptable
to the russians certainly for it to be a
nato force but it's conceivable there
could be some kind of longer-term
peacekeeping force third force under
united nations flag there's a people
aren't really talking about that at the
present moment but it may be that there
has to be some form of policing some
form of
um
international objective uh independent
of the observation of whatever ceasefire
line eventually is agreed whether it's
in the east whether it's along the
crimea line or wherever it is it's
something that may have to be thought
about in future in order to have some
kind of independent monitoring of what
is going on for the future i understand
that but but what about now my lord what
do you think should be happening in the
black sea now
well i i think the nations the navies of
the world could quite reasonably uh be
patrolling offshore
um and monitoring and at least keeping
under observation the the russian navy i
think the
there was a lot of talk early on about
the russians having an amphibious force
that might come ashore at odessa
but uh i think that the likelihood of
that is now quite low
as they have seen the poor performance
of their troops on the ground i think
they'd be very wary about risking the
highly risky uh concept of an amphibious
operation perhaps coming ashore at
odessa so i think for the
the nato navies neighbors of the world
to monitor what the russians are doing
makes a lot of sense and i'm sure
consideration is being given to that
you were very kindly on our program a
couple of weeks ago when you talked
about what's happening uh as far as
putin is concerned and you said that
russia's actions
weren't far off genocide where are you
today
well i think the war crimes are stacking
up to the point that it looks like a
concerted effort to reduce the ukrainian
population and that is getting very
close to
the definition of of genocide and it's
absolutely right and proper that all
these war crimes are being chronicled
evidence is being gathered
now whether or not we'll ever get to a
position where putin or his senior uh
generals
whether there's ever the possibility of
putting them in an international court
in an international dock i don't know
but
if you think back and other people have
made this parallel before to the
dark days the early dark days of the
bosnian civil war it seemed
inconceivable that milosevic and
kharidich and maladic would find their
way into court but they did
and it became perfectly possible to
trace what had happened on the ground
all the way up to them through this
concept of command responsibility such
that they were convicted i gave evidence
twice in the hague against serb generals
and it can be done so it's absolutely
right that war crimes are recorded
evidence is gathered and this is looking
to me increasingly like genocide that is
plotted from the top and the top
therefore must bear responsibility and
maybe one day even if not in a physical
court in the court of history be
condemned
we know that uh mallory that you passed
on your philanthropy to your son and he
does a lot of charity work particularly
uh with ukraine and of course
afghanistan as well i wonder what your
view is
on what we're doing um up to now to
bring ukrainian
nationals into the united kingdom i
think i read something this morning
saying as of last week it was 500.
well we've got to do more we've got to
do better we've got to act more quickly
now the british government has set up a
scheme um i've looked into the detail of
the scheme and the scheme is is there
but we've got to be more agile we've got
to move more quickly um
i live in norfolk the editor of the
eastern daily press david poles was in
ukraine on the polish border last week
and made contact with a large number of
refugees who want to come to this
country and there's a team out there
helping them do the paperwork and get
here but we should be much more agile
much more quick about it um in order to
get those people who are traumatized um
to places of safety and welcome them to
this country
the government
has put a scheme in place but they've
got to
fire it up they've got to speed it up
they've got to do better we owe it to
those people who have become victims and
survivors of that war that war which the
ukrainians are fighting but they're
fighting it on behalf of all of us for
freedom and the rule of law we've got to
do better we've got to move more quickly
to help more people
okay thank you thanks a lot thanks james
well the images of bodies that have come
out of the town of butcher on the
outskirts of kiev over the past few days
have sparked outrage right around the
world as you would expect our security
and defense editor deborah haynes has
visited the town where officials are
investigating the killings of civilians
her report contains distressing images
of bodies
this is no ordinary crime scene
behind the cordon yellow plaques
numbered from one to six are all that
distinguished the remains of one life
from another
each body burnt beyond recognition
like so many victims in the town of
butcher their identities are not yet
known
but what is clear is ukraine's resolve
for justice and its rage at russia
[Music]
[Music]
um
how can you talk to vladimir putin when
his forces do this
go to hell
[Applause]
a sentiment also felt keenly by the body
collectors of butcher their van arrived
already loaded
the police chief says some twelve
hundred war crimes have been registered
so far across the whole kyiv region
viciously
[Music]
the destruction in this town stands
testimony to the trauma unleashed when
russian troops invaded
their withdrawal a few days ago means
investigators can more freely gather
eyewitness statements fingerprints and
video evidence
but living with such death is almost too
much for the remaining residents to bear
who do you blame for this
we've not been here very long but in
this small corner of butcher we've
already counted eight bodies there are
many more houses and gardens yet to be
searched ukrainians say that every death
is going to be investigated and cases
built so that prosecutions for war
crimes can be heard
down the road three more stolen lives
discarded in death
but further evidence for ukraine's
investigators
their goal is justice so the victims of
russia's war can finally rest in peace
debrahing sky news butcher
ali is here we're chatting to the health
secretary about this weren't we and he
stopped short of saying regime changed
but he was absolutely appalled and
continues to be appalled about what's
happening um in ukraine um also wanted
to talk to us in more detail about
what's going to happen here because
there's a national insurance rise from
today yeah that's right that's going to
be the big domestic story today we know
that already this month we've had energy
bills rising for lots of people we've
had council tax rising this is the
controversial national insurance rise
breaking a conservative manifesto pledge
we know that the chancellor in the
spring statement raised the threshold at
which people start to pay national
insurance that means that if you earn
less than about 35 000 pounds actually
you won't necessarily that comes in in
july it's all a bit complicated but over
the year you won't necessarily have to
pay more but for everyone earning above
that this is going to add to all of the
other costs the impact that people are
feeling we know that inflation is being
dwarfed um by benefits so it benefits
rather being dwarfed by inflation so
it's having a big impact on a lot of
people okay alice take at nine o'clock
looking forward to it thanks very much
ellie thank you
so um what happens now what impact will
the images from ukraine have on the
course of the war in ukraine well on
thursday mark will be speaking to one of
putin's closest advisors and that's his
press secretary dmitry peskov you can
watch it live on skype
meantime you can see davey has joined us
lots to talk about this morning thanks
for joining us on the program should we
start with cost of living national
insurance uh is going up today um let's
put that to the health secretary he says
there's no alternative i disagree when
people are facing huge rises in their
energy bills food bills cost of filling
the car
this is just the wrong time for the
conservatives to be adding all these
unfair tax rises remember it's not just
a nash insurance tax rise they've frozen
the income tax allowance during bringing
lots of low paid people into tax for the
first time this is just the wrong timing
when people are struggling so much
that's why liberal democrats are arguing
for an emergency tax cut we think vat
should come down to 17 and a half
percent that would give people on
average 600 pounds a year in
less vat that's the sort of bold measure
that's needed given these difficult
times how do you make that calculation
well um first of all it's going to cost
about 18 billion so it's quite a big
measure but if you look at the fine
print of the the budget statement
they're dragging in 40 billion pounds in
extra vat because of inflation because
prices are going up the chancellor gets
gets extra money from vat so i i think
the least he could do
is use this tax cut that liberal
democrats are putting forward to help
people okay um you say that
the average family
will pay an extra 430 pounds in vat
compared to last year how do you make
that calculation well if you look at the
amount of money that they were
predicting
a year ago from vat the receipts into
the exchequer because
inflation's gone up so much and is
predicted to go up much the government
is now uh forecasting the independent
office of budget responsibilities now
forecasting they'll rake in
38.2 billion pounds extra over this
parliament that's a huge amount of extra
tax and if you break that down on a
yearly basis for every family it's over
400 pounds in vat this year alone on top
of national insurance on top of freezing
uh income tax allowance that's why we
think the conservatives just lost the
plot they are piling on these unfair tax
risers time and again when people are
struggling with uh with their bills yeah
but the chance i mean the chancellor was
a hero wasn't he during the pandemic he
managed to keep so many people still
being paid week after week after week
under the furlough scheme he's got to
pay for it somehow well liberal
democrats supported the furlough scheme
and that's right and let's have
cross-party agreement where we can
however we've got to look at fair ways
of raising the money that we need so
liberal democrats were the first party
to argue for a windfall tax on the
soaring profits of the oil and gas
companies it's just wrong that their
profiteering so much from this rise in
oil and gas prices which is hitting
businesses and of course hitting
families and pensioners across the uk so
democrats want a fairer system where we
tax the profits the with the windfall
tax of the oil and gas companies and use
that to cut taxes on on families um on
monday i think it was yeah monday uh the
world secretary sat exactly where you
are now simon hearts and he told us that
the world has moved on from partygate
has it
i don't think so um i've been going up
and down the country talking to people
ahead of the local elections i was in
hull of other week some set the week
before so around the country and it's
something that the ordinary people are
bringing up unprompted
i think they feel that um boris johnson
is not a decent prime minister that he's
broken uh the law that he's lied to
parliament and they expect more from a
prime minister and what's really
staggering is lifelong conservative
voters
don't think he's a decent prime minister
that's what we found in cheshire amisham
when we beat the conservatives liberal
democrats beat the conservatives in true
blue buckinghamshire what we found in
north shropshire a seat held by the
conservatives for 200 years liberal
democrats beat them and part of the
reason that another reason was ambulance
waiting times and the awful deal for
farmers that the government have
concluded but another reason was
lifelong conservatives saying this tory
prime minister boris johnson is not fit
to be prime minister gonna have to
unpack that for you because we don't
know that the prime minister's broken
the law we'll have to wait and see what
the police say he certainly looks as
though he has uh presided over law
breaking in downing street is that
enough for him uh to step down some
might say and also we've heard from the
ukrainian leader who's praising him to
the skies
well let's deal with ukraine because
that's such a critical uh issue
um i'm actually quite uh in praise of
ben wallace ben is the second secretary
yeah he's a secretary of state for
defense and he's been leading the
support for ukraine uh president obama
no doubt is praising johnson the real
person i think we should all praise is
actually ben wallace and here you are me
a liberal democrat praising conservative
minister because i'm trying to be
balanced but boris johnson we've now
begun to see
through him and i was at school in my
conditions the other day and unprompted
these teenage people said sir was it a
party or was it a work event and i said
to them you tell me do you know what
they said it was a party you know people
can see for their own eyes what happened
i think the prime minister should resign
before i think tory mps should have
sacked him uh for his fate to resign
and frankly whether or not the met
police ultimately give him one of these
notices uh the people in mike's agency
and around the country they've passed
the judgment he's guilty of breaking the
law even if he is and even if he has
misled parliament we'll have to wait to
see the opposition which includes you
and and the snp and of course labour
doesn't seem to have enough strength to
do anything about it now you'll say to
me that it has to be uh
tory back benches that make the
difference but there has to be some
strong arm tactics from the opposition
as well and just doesn't seem to be
there yeah but your viewers have got
some power in this they've got to say
your viewers if they send a message at
the ballot box in the local elections i
would argue by electing strong local
liberal democrat champions in the local
council sends a really powerful message
they can help get rid of boris johnson
so your viewers
i really want to tell them this
tell the conservative party tell boris
johnson tell conservative mps that he
has to go and if they don't will you eat
your words
well um i think from the one people i've
spoken to they want to do that
we should we saw that they did that in
cheshire we saw they did that in north
shropshire where liberal democrats beat
conservatives when no one expected us to
and my feeling from the doorsteps is
that the voters want this prime minister
to go they don't think he's decent they
don't think he's fair and the way he and
rishi sunap the chancellor have
responded to the cost of living crisis
is frankly a scandal they either don't
seem to care they don't get it and
they're doing absolutely nothing that's
not acceptable
if they don't if my loyal viewers do not
vote against the prime minister do you
have to acknowledge that we've moved on
from partygate well i don't like
predicting what the voters are going to
do before they have done it so let's
wait to see certainly the evidence is
they are very unhappy with uh the prime
minister rightly not just for partygate
but for the way he's been running the
country um and let's see i mean i'm
pretty uh optimistic i think if you go
around the country you know i was uh in
harrogate the other day i'm going
wimbledon today we're picking up in
those little democrat battlegrounds uh
that people want to send the government
a message and and i can't blame them
given how badly they've handled both
party gate and the cost of living lots
of uh labour politicians who've been
sitting where you are um have said to me
that they want which you soon actually
go for partygate
indiscretions as well what do you think
well um the evidence on him is less than
the prime minister the evidence against
the prime minister i think is
overwhelming um there is certainly
evidence against the chancellor um i i
probably haven't viewed that as
carefully as i should i i think the
chance that the law sure
certainly has a lot of questions to
answer over particularly that is
absolutely if he's broken the law should
he if he's broken or should go of course
and if he's broken that way if he gets a
fixed penalty notice he's broken the law
yeah and he would get a fixed penalty
notice if he was in the cabinet room
when there was cake yeah
listen see where i'm going with this
yeah yeah well i mean i i think you're
right to go there i think you're right i
mean people expect your viewers expect
politicians who set the rules that they
should keep the rules there's not one
rule for them and another all for the
rest of us that is just unfair it's not
british it's not the tradition of our
great country
and if boris johnson and rishi sunaka
are trouncing the rule of law entrancing
british traditions that is not
acceptable and they should go okay
um unfortunately i'd love to talk to you
for longer but we're out of time so
we're going to have to leave it there
thank you very much we'll see weren't we
at prime minister's questions i'm sure
you'll be asking a question later on for
now thanks very much indeed thanks a lot
that's about it for the first hour of
the program